Britain is due to leave the European  Union on the 31st of January MEP s want  assurances about the protection of  European citizens rights in the UK  Parliament supports the European Green  Deal proposed by the Commission but  seeks a more ambitious emissions  reduction goal of 55 percent by 2030  members want to involve Europeans from  all backgrounds in citizen meetings to  generate ideas on EU reform the project  called the conference on the future of  Europe will run for two years the Lisbon  treaty article 7 process examines  whether a member state has infringed  fundamental EU values such as freedom of  expression or rule of law Parliament  says that no progress has been made  since this article was triggered against  Poland and Hungary in light of the  problems facing biodiversity MEP s want  30 percent of EU territory to consist of  natural areas by 2030  you